саме Україна визначає коли має
закінчитися ця війна
кожен день зволікання коштує життів
українських військових помірних жителів
усі реактивні літаки важливі Тому що це
частина наших зусиль зі знищення
російських ракет
рис тому для нас Важливо щоб ми зупинили
російську агресію і витіснили росіян з
усіх окупованих територій у тому числі з
Криму через
заклик до міжнародної спільноти
потурбуватися щоб жодна війна ніколи
більше не могла розпочатися з боку Росії
після нашої спільної Перемоги
Дякую що долучились до ДВК давайте
розпочнемо з літаків винищувачів слів
нині дуже активно просуває дебати щодо
надання винищувачів чому ці літаки такі
важливі для України
усі реактивні літаки важливі Тому що це
частина наших зусиль зі знищення
російських ракет
найнебезпечніша річ з якою нам на жаль
доводиться стикатися щодня
Росія запускає багато ракет по
українських містах інфраструктурі
частина наших зусиль щодо
звісно ви як посол України в Берліні
зосереджені на німецьких дебатах але
канцлер ФРН офшольц вже позиціонує себе
дуже скептично щодо відправки
винищувачів в Україні він сказав що ці
дебати є дивними що вони схожі
перетворюються на торги які ведуть різні
люди керуючись внутрішньополітичними
інтересами Що ви на це скажете
дуже послідовними в розмовах з різними
міжнародними партнерами
та шукали яке обладнання ми можемо від
них отримати
пріоритети Як послать тут і самого
початку
це бронетехніка основні бойові танки
системи ППО та артилерійські установки
Ми дуже добре просуваємося за всіма
чотирма пріоритетами
ми будемо продовжувати говорити з нашими
німецькими партнерами переважно щодо цих
чотирьох пріоритетів
Але звичайно ситуація на полі бою може
вимагати іншого обладнання
моїми пріоритетами як я вже сказав є
системи протиповітряної оборони основні
бойові танки бронетехніка артилерія
потребує припаси
щоб пояснити сказане вами Ви як
представник українського уряду І
заявляєте що вам насправді не потрібні
реактивні винищувачі з Німеччини це те
що ви кажете
нам не потрібні підводні човни крейсери
та інші НЛО з Німеччини А як щодо
винищувачів Ми поки що не надсилали
жодного запиту Німеччині щодо
винищувачів тобто цей запит ще може
надійти
це залежатиме від ситуації на полі бою
знову ж таки якщо я отримую від наших
військових такий запит ми будемо
працювати з нашими партнерами Але знову
ж таки За зачиненими дверима Та у
довірливому середовищі
дуже сильно критикували тут у Німеччині
а також на заході з тівагання які ми
спостерігали щодо танків які Німеччина
врешті-решт погодилася поставити а також
дозволила іншим Україна постачати ці
німецькі танки Володимир Зеленський ваш
президент виступаючи на всесвітньому
економічному форумі в давосі на початку
року сказав що час який вільний світ
використовує для роздумів терористична
держава використовує для вбивств Як ви
вважаєте ці дебати які так довго
тривають в Німеччині чи справді вони
ставлять Україну під загрозу
ви знаєте Незабаром буде річниця
повномасштабного російського вторгнення
в Україну
Спілкуючись з нашими партнерами та
друзями Ми сподіваємося що вони
розуміють що насправді Україна бореться
за життя за існування і незалежність
і щодня поки ми тут обговорюємо і
дискутуємо всередині країни або
домовляємося про правила взаємодії з
партнерами гинуть українські солдати
гинуть українські мирні
жителін
і саме тому так важливо щоб ця дискусія
відбувалася
якнайшвидшей
щоб ми якнайшвидше отримали поставки
зброї та боєприпасів
кожен день зволікання коштує життів
українських військових і мирних жителів
Ukraine Україна цього року має на меті
зосередитися на повернення окупованих
російською стороною території ми бачили
що Минулого року Україна вже досягла
значних успіхів у Херсоні та Харкові
і хоче досягти прогресу на Донбасі
і щодо Криму Поясніть чому Україна хоче
повернути Крим
тому що крім це окупована територія
окупована Російською Федерацією і що
важливо ми говоримо про відновлення
суверенітету України згідно з міжнародно
визнаними кордонами
найголовніше - це звільнення наших людей
на окупованих територіях
і ми знаємо наскільки там погана
ситуація під російською окупацією
всі і ми бачили світлини зі звільнених
Бучі ізюма Херсона
дуже багато українських співвітчизників
досі перебувають у полоні російського
окупаційного режиму на Сході та на
півдні України і в окупованому Криму
на жаль про звірство російських
окупаційних військ ми дізнаємося коли
звільнимо ці території і коли звільнимо
наших людей
а от people тому для нас Важливо щоб ми
зупинили російську агресію і витіснили
росіян з усіх окупованих територій у
тому числі з Криму
Як ви вважаєте чи реально повернути Крим
Він має величезне значення для
Володимира Путіна Там російська
військово-морська база
я не думаю що нам потрібно прийматися
тим що важливо для Володимира Путіна
особисто чи для росіян і Кремля
Росія вчинила акт агресії ще в 2014 році
і ми бачили що світ намагався вплинути
на Путіна за допомогою санкцій
його міжнародної діяльності ізоляції
Росії але це не спрацювало
і Путін пішов далі і розпочав
широкомасштабну війну в Європі
у XXI столітті Отже в наших інтересах і
в інтересах усіх наших міжнародних
партнерів Зупинити цю агресивну зміну з
боку Росії та допомогти Україні виграти
цю війну
Ukraine
Я хотів би продовжити тему Криму тому що
звичайно з міжнародної та юридичної
точки зору ви абсолютно праві і навряд
чи якась країна визнала російський
контроль над Кримом і все ж у столицях є
побоювання що спроба повернути Крим може
призвести до небезпечної ескалації
можливо до застосування ядерної зброї ви
розумієте ці занепокоєння
ми розуміємо занепокоєння і ми ведемо
поглиблений діалог і переговори з нашими
партнерами щодо планування та пояснення
наших наступних кроків
і ми маємо повну підтримку усіх
міжнародних партнерів і всі знають що
саме Україна визначає коли має
закінчитися ця війна
і озброєних сил України та у народу
України немає іншого виходу
Я повністю звільнити українську
територію
та витіснити російські сили назад Росії
з півдня із сходу України та з Криму
Зеленський президент Зеленський
представив покроковий план припинення
війни ключовим серед цих 10 пунктів є
заклад до гарантій безпеки для України
Чи не могли б ви пояснити що саме він
має на увазі які гарантії хоче отримати
Україна яка приміром роль Сполучених
Штатів таких гарантіях яка роль великих
важливих європейських країн таких як
Німеччина
є кілька опцій на столі і Мирний план
президента Зеленського з 10 кроків зараз
широко обговорюється з усіма
міжнародними партнерами
і ми маємо повну підтримку Німеччини та
Сполучених Штатів щодо цього
дійсно ми бачили що усі угоди які були
підписані з Росією як і наш великий
договір з Російською Федерацією де Росія
зобов'язалася визнати незалежність і
територіальну цілісність України
ці договори те саме сталося її з
мінськими угодами які Росія не хотіла
виконувати від самого початку
до міжнародної спільноти потурбуватися
щоб жодна війна ніколи більше не могла
розпочатися з боку Російської Федерації
після того як ми разом переможемо у цій
війні проти Росії
Але чи могли б ми тоді детальніше
розібратися в цих гарантіях які Як ви
вважаєте запобігли повторенню такої
війни щоб ви хотіли щоб гарантували
Сполучені Штати щоб ви хотіли щоб
гарантувала Німеччина
це те що ми думали що отримали від
Будапештського меморандуму ще в 1994
році але на жаль це були не гарантії а
запевнення в безпеці і Ми зрозуміли що
на жаль Росія порушила той Будапештський
меморандум де
будапештною безпекової підтримки в США
Великобританії та інших ядерних держав
nations
для всіх країн світу
що насправді тільки ядерна зброя може
врятувати їх від нападу такого агресора
Ось чому ми хочемо розпочати цю дискусію
як це може виглядати
була представлена нашим президентом на
початку минулого року
а не це обговорюється наразі в усіх
столицях
Важливо щоб увесь світ подбав про те щоб
ці гарантії були підкріплені конкретними
інструментами
як зробити так щоб Росія їх не порушила
пане макеєв Дуже дякую за розмову з ДВ
дякую вам